Pock oder nicht Pock, das ist die Frage her, Gigapock, Hyperpock,
Omegapock gibt es sowas auch schon, lasst euch nicht verwirren, dass ich nichts sage,
ich bin auch da, ich suche gerade was aber irgendwie, ich habe so viel Gerümpel hier
an Technikrams hier auf meinem Basteltisch rumliegen, ich finde es nicht,
naja gut kann ich auch nachher suchen, ist jetzt wirklich wichtig, dass ich das im Stream suche,
ja weil ich habe nämlich was gekauft, wo wir zusammen basteln können im Stream,
bin ich mal gespannt, ob es funktioniert und zwar habe ich, das kann sein, dass ich das schon
mal gezeigt habe sogar, du hast gestern im Community Discord offen, sag mal geht,
kann man in Discord noch joinen, in der Eingangshalle ist am 31.3. zuletzt jemand
gejoint, aber das kann nicht sein, das ist ein halbes Jahr her fast und ich habe neue Leute gesehen,
Ausrufezeichen Discord, falls mal jemand ausprobieren will und nicht drin ist,
kann man in Discord noch joinen, man muss gehen, wie gesagt ich habe neue Leute gesehen,
aber in der Eingangshalle steht erst seit dem 31.3. steht nichts mehr drin, ist komisch,
sehr merkwürdig, genau was ich euch zeigen wollte, ich habe hier bestellt ESP32-CAM-Hodule,
so welche hier, kam es gerade rein und stand in der Eingangshalle was, wobei ich kann ja
selbst nachgucken, ich muss mal bloß Display Capture ausmachen, dass ich nicht wieder in
merkwürdigen Discords unterwegs bin, wo ich irgendwas leaken könnte jetzt oder PM-Messages
oder sonst was, alles klar, in der Eingangshalle steht einfach gar nichts mehr, na super, wisst ihr,
ich habe mich hier gewundert, guckt mal, Eingangshalle steht einfach zuletzt was,
haben die das abgeschaltet bei Discord, verstehe ich nicht, erstmal, nein, erstmal alles liken,
wer boostet, Poggers, ok, komisch, sehr, sehr merkwürdig, all gut, just me, Dankeschön
für den Prime-Sub, genau, also hiervon habe ich zwei Minuten bestellt und wisst ihr was
ich damit machen will, ich will damit meinen Druck an der Heizung im Keller auslesen,
das geht folgendermaßen, da habe ich ein Projekt gefunden auf GitHub, ich glaube,
ich habe es euch schon mal gezeigt, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, hat der Nightbot eigentlich
jetzt wieder was gepostet und da kann man AI gesteuert, also Massive Big Brain, heute ist ja
alles AI, auch wenn man keine AI braucht, Hauptsache AI, ist euch mal aufgefallen, was, Blockchain,
aber AI ist angesagter, ach stimmt, heute ist Sysadmin-Day, ja, richtig, hatte ich ganz vergessen
und ist euch mal aufgefallen, wie Microsoft und Apple und alle jeden Scheiß mittlerweile
mit AI bewerben, so nach dem Motto, neue Foto-App, AI, neues Windows, AI, neue Nachrichten-Feed,
Nachrichten-Feed, AI, also das wird mittlerweile überall rein gefrickelt, dieses Wort, ob
man das da braucht oder nicht, zumindest, das Ding kann, also so eine hässliche Kiste
mache ich da nicht, aber man kann mit einem ESP32-Cam-Modul und dieser Software kann man
angeblich den Zählerstand auslesen, sowohl, also das sind ja keine wirklichen digitalen,
was sind das eigentlich für Anzeigen, das sind analoge Anzeigen, das sind eigentlich
digitale Anzeigen, aber das ist eine halbanaloge Anzeige, weil die rollt ja langsam rüber,
das ist so eine digitale Anzeige mit Zwischenschritten, ich weiß nicht wie ich das nennen soll, halbanaloge,
halb digitale Anzeige, so und der kann beispielsweise hier auslesen, mit Bilderkennungs-Magic-Fivehead-AI,
dass das hier beispielsweise gerade 6,8 ist, oder so ungefähr, was ziemlich nice ist,
guck sieht man ja hier, 38, corrected value 38, 5, äh, sieht hier irgendjemand ne 5, ah
hier guck mal, 5, habe ich gesagt 6,8, 5,9, 9, ach was auch immer, zumindest kann man das
damit auslesen, das will ich ausprobieren, da kann man auch sein Stromzähler mitgeschaltet
auslesen, das muss ich, das muss ich alles mal testen, so und das probieren wir mal aus
in einem der nächsten Streams, ich hab gerade die Module gesucht, wo ich die hingeschmissen
hab, bin ich mal gespannt, ob das so 5-headig ist wie es aussieht, Qtbot geht wieder, dazu
kann ich nur sagen, Massive, nice, gg eats, vadergang subscribt 25 Monate, ja ich bräuchte
jetzt einen doppelten Hyper-Subscriber, Leute wisst ihr was, ohne Scheiß, wisst ihr was
ich jetzt mal wirklich langsam brauch, ich brauch noch 8 gescheite Emotes, dass meine
Emotes slots voll sind und ich brauch endlich mal Badges, ich hab hier gar keine Badges,
ich hab den Keks in klein, ich brauch Badges, gescheite Badges und endlich mal noch 8 Emotes,
dass die Emotes slots endlich voll sind, Badge, nein irgendwas was für meinen Channel von
jemand erstellt wurde, nicht einfach irgendwelche komischen, ich mein wir könnten, wir könnten
Badge mit dem Keks machen, was haltet ihr denn davon, Badge mit Keks, dass da quasi
der Keks hier drunter liegt, wer das machen wird, ja halte ich nicht zurück, direkt Leute
mal Pfeiffer bezahlen, ja ich brauch auf jeden Fall irgendwie 8 Emotes und noch Badges muss
ich mich kümmern, ich kann ja natürlich nicht immer alles andere Leute machen lassen,
aber Dankeschön, 25 Spore oder Hyper Subscription, was hältst du von den Fortbildungen bei der
IHK, wenn du diese Fachwertgeschichten meinst, ich weiß es nicht, ich kann das nicht richtig
einschätzen, also man kann ja bei der IHK nach der Ausbildung, kann man ja noch so komische
Dinge machen, wo ich bis heute nicht gecheckt hab, was die bringen, wenn ich ehrlich bin,
da kann man dann Fachwert und Techniker oder irgendwie sowas, irgendwie so komische Dinge,
ich hab's bis heute nicht gecheckt und irgendwie interessiert das glaub ich auch kein, IT Operative
Professionals, ich hab noch nie jemand gesehen, der diese Ausbildung hat, ich hab auch noch
nicht gesehen, ob das überhaupt irgendjemand interessiert, wenn man die hat, ich kann es
null einschätzen, aber nachdem ich es, also ich kann es dadurch, dass ich es noch nie
gehört oder gesehen hab in Freibildbahn, zumindest eher negativ einschätzen, dass es wahrscheinlich
keinen großartig interessiert, aber so wirklich, keine Ahnung, man kann nach der Ausbildung,
ich glaube es geht aber übrigens nicht direkt nach der Ausbildung, ich glaube man braucht
dann irgendwie 5 Jahre Berufserfahrung oder irgendwie sowas, Certified IT Business Consultant,
geprüfte IT Berater, wisst ihr was die beste Prüfung für den IT Berater ist, wenn er Ahnung
hat, was interessiert mich, ob ein IT Berater geprüft ist, wenn er keine Ahnung hat, von
dem was er erzählt, also ich finde das Wort Consultant wird so verschwenderisch verwendet,
jeder Volldepp hat bei sich irgendwie Consultant dranstehen, obwohl ich den im Leben nicht
zu irgendwas konsultieren würde, ja, Consultant heißt ja für mich, das ist jemand, den frage
ich, wenn ich selber nicht weiter weiß oder keinen hab, der davon Ahnung, wenn ich selbst
keine Ahnung von hab, auf gut Deutsch gesagt, so, dann hole ich mir einen Consultant, aber
das wird so inflationär verwendet und so viele Low-Brain-Oi-3-Head-Leute sind als Consultant
unterwegs, das ist total verwässert, hast du irgendwelche guten Ressources mit dem ESP32
einzusteigen, ja, ich mach mal meine VM an, zeige ich dir, flame über den Florian, ich
kann nur über den Florian flame, vielleicht ist er ein guter Consultant, keine Ahnung,
kann auch sein, dass es ein guter Consultant ist, oh je, oh Mist, wie war das nochmal,
das hatten wir schon mal, nice, 10 Millionen Euro, Dankeschön, Adi, wie war das, Lock-Ordner
löschen war das doch, ne, C, Doppelpunkte X, VMs, Jubandu 1204, Poggers, Poggers, Poggers-Lock
muss ich glaube ich löschen, Poggers-Lock, kann man das einfach so löschen ohne, ohne
dass es prickt, ah geht, ok, easy, easy, easy, ja also ich zeig dir gleich was zu Ressourcen
mit dem ESP32, ich muss erst mal kurz meine VM einschalten, ja aber wie gesagt, also,
das wird so inflatz und, jetzt muss ich, ist ein bisschen laut, Donkey Kong Musik ne, traurig,
ist das Gametrain am Start, Level 1 Complete, ja ja Chain-Lore ist klar, bei zu mir fällt
es nicht auf, dass das Fake-Message ist, dein Ausbilder war operational, professional,
ja, ich kann dazu, ich kann dazu nichts sagen, keine Ahnung, zumindest das Wort Consultant
triggert mich immer, weil das, das wirkt so, als hätten die Leute Ahnung, ich kenn so
viele Consultants, die absolut keinen Schimmer haben von dem, was sie da eigentlich machen,
wo ich mich immer frage, was ist das, was ist denn das eigentlich für Consultants, was,
ich überleg grad, was war der unfähigste Consultant, den wir jemals hatten, ja, doch
einer sticht da heraus, einer sticht da heraus, wir hatten mal nen Consultant, den wollten
wir konsultieren für Monitoring-Systeme, glaube ich war das, und den haben sie geholt,
haben eine Notebook in die Hand gedrückt und haben gesagt, so hier, hast du deine Notebook,
da ist dein Arbeitsplatz, leg mal los, und nach eineinhalb Wochen hat ihn dann sein damaliger
Chef gefragt, ja und, hat dich schon irgendjemand eingearbeitet oder irgendjemand was gezeigt
oder so, so wie siehts denn aus, und dann meintet er nach eineinhalb Wochen ernsthaft, ich richte
immer noch mein Notebook ein, der hat es quasi, der war dann auch nur zwei Wochen oder drei
Wochen da, also sprich, der hat drei Wochen gebraucht, um sein Notebook einzurichten, bei
seinem Consultantgehalt, und dann war er wieder weg, also die, die, ich weiß nicht was das
gekostet hat, wahrscheinlich 5000 Euro oder so, da kamen ja, die Leute sind ja ultra teuer,
das hat sich, das hat sich wahnsinnig gelohnt, das hat, das hat es wahnsinnig gelohnt, also
das war glaube ich echt der unfähigste Consultant, den wir hier hatten, ohne hatten wir noch
mal einen, der war auch ziemlich planlos, ich weiß nicht mal welcher, da hab ich jetzt
kein Bild mehr vor Augen, aber, der sollte damals auch Monitoring, lustigerweise, der
sollte damals unseren Zappix umziehen, also von der alten auf die neue Version, und er
hat es komplett kaputt gemacht, das ging dann einfach irgendwie in keiner und zwei Wochen
gar nicht mehr, den hatten wir auch nicht lang, achja und, und noch aus dem Storage
Bereich, kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern, da hatten wir auch einen ganz tollen Consultant,
er hat, er ist in unser Storage System gegangen und das ist langsam vollgelaufen, so und,
da hat er sich gedacht, er macht jetzt den Big Brain Move, er will, so nach dem Motto,
ich spare der Firma jetzt 500.000 Euro oder so und da krieg ich was von ab oder so, keine
Ahnung, dann hat er, hat er richtig Big Brain Move gemacht und da ist er in die Firmware
vom Storage System und hat Kompression und Deed Application eingeschaltet, obwohl der
Hersteller sogar sagt, dass es bei unserer Auslastung und bei unserem Workload auf dem
Storage keine gute Idee ist und das war instant, er hat den Knopf gedrückt und das Ding war
einfach von brauchbar schnell zu unbenutzbar langsam, ja, den gab's, nee, kein NetApp,
es war kein NetApp, es war ein, lass mal überlegen, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es noch IBM
war oder schon Dell Storage, ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, zumindest, das könnte dir wahrscheinlich
mit allem passieren, wenn die Leute den Kram verwenden, wie es nicht verwendet werden soll.
Ja, das waren so meine Top 6 Head oder eher 3 Head Consultants, genau und jetzt mal ganz
schnell eine Sache, achso, das ist auch was man, Firefox, wer auch immer gerade gefragt
nach der ESP32 Ressource, das ist ganz einfach, du gehst dahin, das ist ne Visual Studio Extensions
und installierst dir das hier, das hier installierst du als Visual Studio Extensions, dann stöpselst
du dein ESP32 dran und kannst loslegen, mehr brauchst du nicht, dann machst du halt Hello
World und guckst dir ein paar Examples an, aber du musst nichts großartig installieren,
Visual Studio Code, diese Extensions draufhauen, ESP anstöpseln und loslegen, das ist das
beste Komplettpaket, was du so nehmen kannst aktuell.
So, exellent, bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben, genau, also das probieren wir in einem der
nächsten Streams aus, hier Big Brain AI, gesteuerte, wie nennt man das, Tacho, ne, Nadel, wie heißt
denn das, wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch, so ne Anzeige, ok, mal gucken, ne, das trifft
nicht so ganz, was, Rundinstrument, ja, warum, ne, ja ne, keine Ahnung, ich mein nicht was
ist mit so ne Art, aber Rundinstrument finde ich schonmal gut, naja, so, das probieren wir
dann, das probieren wir dann im nächsten aus, habt ihr mitbekommen, so, habt ihr mitbekommen
die Geschichte mit dem Telekom Ausfall, das hier, glaub Heise hatte was zugeschrieben,
also vorgestern, nicht heute, Telekom, meine Güte, Telekom, Heise, das da, habt ihr das
mitbekommen bei der Telekom, das finde ich ist ne wirklich interessante Geschichte, was
da dahinter steckt, ich hab mir überlegt ob ich da nicht ein Video zu aufnehme, weil
die Telekom kann für diesen Telekom Ausfall gar nix, das ist mal ne Telekom, es haben alle
richtig wieder auf die Telekom geschissen, ja, auch auf, auch auf Twitter und überall,
aber gut, ich mein, die Chance, dass es an der Telekom liegt, ist ja bei Telekom Ausfällen
auch relativ hoch, aber die Telekom konnte da für diesmal wirklich nix, das Problem
war ein bulgarischer Internetprovider und Microsoft in Kombination, die Telekom kann,
kann, kann da gar nix für, die Telekom Fluthilfe Videos haben wir schon geguckt, ja, da wollte
ich ein Video zu machen, weil, also ich versuch das mal, ich versuch das mal kurz, kurz zu
erklären was da, was da Sache ist, ich überleg grad, ich überleg grad wo ich da, wo ich
da am besten anfange mit, also, hier oben die Überschrift trifft, trifft da schon mal
ganz gut, also BGP, das ist ein Protokoll wo sich, ich versuch das mal, ich bin erstens
jetzt Disclaimer, Nier, du Dankeschön für die, für die Stufe 1 ab, erst mal Disclaimer,
also ich bin jetzt kein Internetnetzwerkspezialist, ne, also ich weiß das in der Theorie her,
nicht spoilern, wie soll ich jetzt post, post, soll ich nix, ok Chat, ich sag nix dazu, soll
ich was sagen oder soll ich nix sagen, ich weiß, dass der Chat eh sagt, dass ich was
zu sagen soll, was sonst, also, ich weiß, also wie gesagt, ich bin kein, ich bin kein
super Netzwerkspezialist, aber, also bisschen, ein bisschen Ahnung hab ich davon auch, ja,
also BGP ist ein Protokoll wo vereinfacht gesagt, Provider untereinander austauschen,
wer welches Netz bedient, ja, also z.B. die Telekom hat in dem Fall Netz, das Netz gehabt,
mal, das hab ich sogar irgendwo gelesen, ja, dann, dann, keine Ahnung, ähm, also
ich, ich wusste, ich, ich hab, ich hab mir nämlich hier was, was aufgeschrieben zu, hab
ich grad in meinen Notizen geguckt, ich hab mir das Netz nicht dazu aufgeschrieben, ist
auch egal, also, ich such's, ich such, dann suchen wir das gleich hier mal raus zusammen
im Stream, also, die Telekom hat unterschiedlichste Netze, ja, IP Netze, keine Ahnung, 8, 2, ich,
ich such da, ich such Netz, ich, wir machen das jetzt mal ein bisschen detaillierter,
nach was suche ich denn da, Telekom, AS, äh, 3, 3, oh, was weiß ich, das weiß ich schon
im Kopf nicht, wie das, oh, müssen wir mal kurz gucken, auf Twitter hat irgendwie einer
glaube ich was interessantes geschrieben dazu, da konnte man das raussuchen, hier, da, da
steht's, genau, also, ähm, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kann ich's erklären, also es ging um
dieses Netz, 87, 128, 0016, so, jetzt machen wir mal Big Brain, weil wir zu dumm sind,
aus dem Kopf IP Adressen zu berechnen, machen wir jetzt IP Kalk, und gucken uns das mal
an, also, es geht um dieses IP Netz, sprich, von, äh, 8, 7, 1, 2, 8, 00, bis, äh, ich
wass denn hier, natürlich, das, das da, von, äh, 8, 7, 1, 2, 8, 01, bis, äh, 8, 7, 1,
9, 1, 2, 5, 5, 2, 5, 4, also in Slash 10, da passen schon, passen schon, ihr seht's
ja schon, da passen, äh, 4.194.302 Server, oder Host, oder Client, oder je nachdem, Geräte,
Endpunkte rein, Client, ja, so, das ist das, das ist eines der IP Netze, die die Telekom
verwendet, für die DSL-Anschlüsse, soweit ich weiß, ich weiß, ihr guckt manchmal Telekom
Leute zu, ihr könnt mich gerne korrigieren, wenn ich Mist erzähle, das ist ein Netz, was
die Telekom für DSL-Anschlüsse verwendet, also sprich, wenn ihr den Telekom DSL-Anschluss
habt, dann ist die Chance relativ hoch, dass ihr eine IP bekommt, aus diesem Netz, mitbekommen
das Hetzener Cloud Server teurer werden wegen IPv4, ey, da kann ich auch gleich, äh, auch
gleich, gleich was zu sagen, ja, also, ihr bekommt wahrscheinlich aus diesem Netz eine
IP, wenn ihr den DSL-Anschluss bei der Telekom habt, so, und jetzt ist folgendes passiert,
die Provider, also besser gesagt die Router, oder noch besser gesagt eigentlich die Edge-Router
von den Providern, die tauschen sich aus, welche Netze bei ihnen zur Verfügung stehen, so,
und nach dem ja ein anderer Provider nicht interessiert, wie intern geroutet wird bei
einem anderen Provider, ne, also, wenn ich jetzt die Telekom bin, interessiert mich nicht,
wie Vodafone intern routet, was mich interessiert ist, was für Netze gibt es bei Vodafone,
und im Zweifelsfall über wie viele Ecken komme ich dahin, das ist das, was mich interessiert,
so, das heißt, die Router schicken sich untereinander eben die Netze zu, die sie kennen, beziehungsweise
die sie, die sie eben haben, und dazu gibt es BGP, und damit man sich da nicht mit so
viel einzelnen Netzen auseinandersetzen muss, beziehungsweise, dass man nicht, ähm, wie
bei, was ist das, ich glaube bei OSPF, sich um so viele Details kümmern muss, fragt mich
nicht im, genau wie das ist, ich mach damit so gut wie nie was, ja, ich hab davon keine
Ahnung, ich hab's noch nie selbst eingerichtet, gibt es zumindest so eine Zuordnung von autonomen
Systemen, die kriegen so eine Nummer, verpasst, und hinter diesen autonomen Systemen, also
AS3320 steckt zum Beispiel die Telekom, und da drinnen zusammengefasst sind die ganzen
Netze, die zu diesem Provider, oder die, die in dem Fall zur Telekom gehören, die Telekom
hat hier noch mehr, das können wir uns jetzt mal angucken, wenn wir sich mal angucken,
wie viele Prefix, das nennt sich Prefix bei BGP, das ist das einzige, was ich noch weiß,
ähm, WTF, was hab ich da aufgemacht, äh, hat jemand eine gute Seite, wo man sich die
Prefixe angucken kann, was ist denn, ja unter anderem ein Netz von der Telekom ist dann
das hier, ip, was, ipinfo.io, was sonst, was, was sonst, so, ja, sowas, sowas, so und da
sehen wir zu AS3320, das ist, das ist quasi auf die, wie kann man sagen, man kann glaube
ich sagen, das ist zur Art auf die Telekom zugelassen, ich weiß es nicht, wie dieses
Mapping im Hintergrund passiert, wo man, ich hab auch keine Ahnung, wo man diese Dinger
beantragt, ob die einfach hochgezählt werden oder, hab ich mich nie mit beschäftigt, zumindest
hinter autonomem System, hinter autonomem System 3320 steckt die deutsche Telekom, ich könnte
mir gut vorstellen, dass die Telekom noch ein paar mehr hat und innerhalb von diesen
AS-Systemen, von diesen autonomen Systemen gibt es halt verschiedene Prefixes, Prefixes
sind quasi IP-Netze, Ranges, so und das sind quasi Ranges, die zur Telekom gehören, die
zu AS3320 gehören, da ist dann zum Beispiel das Auswärtige Amt drin, da ist Freudenberg-NOC-General
Partnership drinne und was auch immer, alles diese IPs, IP-Ranges gehören dazu und auch
die Gabelberger Straße 4, warum, was auch immer die Gabelberger Straße 4 da macht,
was hat die Gabelberger Straße 4 damit zu tun, mit der Telekom, ich weiß es nicht,
das ist die HANA, das glaube ich jetzt eher nicht, was hat die Telekom mit der Gabelberger
Straße 4 zu tun, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung, aber zumindest Gabelberger Straße
4 hat vielleicht die Telekom ein Rechenzentrum oder so, muss die fliegen, danke schön für
den Zap, das sind die IP-Ranges, die zu AS3320 gehören, das ist halt eins von der Telekom,
wir gucken mal, ob das da auch drinne steht, das müsste da nämlich auch drinstehen, ich
weiß es nicht, zumindest, wir müssen mal hier danach suchen, hier guck mal, da steht
es doch, haben wir es doch, das gehört dazu, ja warum das jetzt da unter den IPs nicht
angezeigt, ich weiß es nicht, zumindest, ihr seht, dieses Netz ist Teil von dem BGP, von
dem autonomen BGP-System von der Telekom, so, also AS3320, so was jetzt passiert ist
bei dieser Geschichte ist folgendes, die Telekom kann da wie gesagt gar nichts dazu, ein bulgarischer
Provider, nämlich mit dieser Nummer, also mit dieser BGP autonomen, wie heißt das jetzt
eigentlich genau, AS, autonomus system, hat gesagt, ey Leute, das Netz, das passiert öfters
mal, das passiert öfters mal, so und dieser bulgarische Provider hat quasi announced über
BGP, dass das Netz 8712800-10 jetzt nicht mehr zu autonomem System 3320 gehört, sondern
jetzt Bestandteil von seinem autonomen System 212416 ist, man sieht auch schon an der Nummer,
die Telekom ist deutlich länger dabei als der bulgarische Anbieter, das geht, solange
die Gegenstellen das nicht gegenchecken und was ist jetzt passiert, man weiß übrigens
nicht, ob das der bulgarische Provider absichtlich gemacht hat oder ob die sich vertippt haben,
das kommt öfters mal vor, das kommt so, das kommt so, weiß ich, so 1-2 mal im Jahr kommt
das vor, das kommt immer mal wieder vor und zumindest hat der bulgarische Provider jetzt
gesagt, hey, dieses Netz, wo eben viele DSL IPs von der Telekom drin vergeben werden,
hat jetzt gesagt, gehört zu mir, so, der Microsoft Router hat dieses Announcement von BGP bekommen,
da war vielleicht irgendein Spezialkonsultant schon möglich und daraufhin, also so interpretiere
ich das und daraufhin haben dann die Microsoft Router gesagt, oh, oh, Antworten an Telekom-Kunden
schicken wir jetzt nicht mehr zur Telekom, sondern nach Bulgarien und dann hat der bulgarische
Provider zwar ganz viele Antwortpakete für die Telekom bekommen, aber das hat nichts
gebracht, weil da ist ja kein DSL-Kunde beim bulgarischen Provider, also so interpretiere
ich das, also sprich, die Pakete sind dann vom DSL-Anschluss an Microsoft gegangen und
Microsoft wollte die Pakete zurückschicken und hat geguckt, wo kann ich die Pakete hinschicken,
a, nach Bulgarien jetzt, hat sie nach Bulgarien geschickt und die kam nie an, also die Telekom
kann für diesen Telekom-Ausfall tatsächlich gar nichts, die Telekom kann wirklich nichts
dafür, die Telekom hat nichts, die hat weder, die hat nicht dazu beigetragen und die hat
auch weder dagegen, die war einfach nicht beteiligt daran, das lag daran, dass Microsoft, also
erstens das Problem war, dass der bulgarische Provider überhaupt gesagt hat, hallo, ich
habe auf einmal Prefixe und IP-Ranges von der Telekom und dass Microsoft das einfach
ungeprüft geglaubt hat, sonderlich viel Security ist da nicht, es gibt wohl die Möglichkeit
mittlerweile, dass man PGP irgendwie absichert, aber das ist alles ziemlich auf Vertrauensbasis,
wie sagt man heute auf Ehrenbruderbasis ist das, wer da welchen Provider traut und nachdem
die Provider in der Regel nicht darauf ausgelegt sind, ihre Sachen gegenseitig sich kaputt
zu machen, klappt das eigentlich auch ganz gut, außer irgendwie ein super cleverer Consultant
vertippt sich, ja und das war das Problem bei dem Telekom-Ausfall, das hat nicht sonderlich
lang gedauert, ich glaube zwei Stunden oder so, ja und ja, man sieht da wirklich daran,
wie instabil das eigentlich ist, also wenn man an der falschen Stelle die falschen Sachen
announced, kann man das Internet relativ schnell kaputt machen.
Das ist auch mal ein Thema, da müsste ich mich, ich bin ja netzwerktechnisch, mache
ich ja schon lange nichts mehr großartig, das wäre was, was ich beispielsweise auch
mal gerne ausprobieren würde mit zwei, drei VMs, vielleicht sogar mit irgendeinem Cisco-Emulator
oder so, dass man mal BGP einschaltet, das würde mich einfach mal interessieren, was
man dafür konfigurieren muss, weil wenn man sowas ein, zwei mal konfiguriert hat, versteht
man in der Regel viel besser, was Sache ist, ja, naja, zumindest das ist der Hintergrund
von dieser ganzen Geschichte und ich habe gesehen, es haben einige Newsseiten, ich glaube
heise nicht, aber ich glaube, es haben einige Newsseiten gepostet, das ist ein BGP-Fehler
gewesen, das ist kein BGP-Fehler, ein BGP-Fehler wäre, wenn das Protokoll irgendwie, also
wenn das irgendwie schlecht implementiert wäre bei einem Hersteller, wenn es da eine
Logikfehler im Protokoll gab, BGP hat alles richtig gemacht, irgendein Dapp hat das falsche
eingetragen, das muss man auch mal so klar sagen, wie es ist, wahrscheinlich wirklich
irgendwie ein super hochbezahlter Konsultant in Bulgarien, wobei ich weiß nicht, ob Konsultants
in Bulgarien so hochbezahlt sind, aber der war das, der war das und Microsoft war auch
mit dran schuld, würde ich auf jeden Fall schon sagen, weil die einfach ohne da irgendwie
sich Gedanken zu machen diese Announcements akzeptieren, ich meine, das ist ja nicht jetzt
irgendwie ein kleiner Feldwald und Wiesen Provider, wir reden ja hier von der Telekom
und Microsoft, also sowohl Telekom als auch Microsoft sind jetzt ja keine kleinen
Anbieter und mit kleinen oder mit wenigen Netzen, ja, genau, hier steht noch ein paar
mehr Informationen drin, aber ich glaube, das, was ich jetzt erzählt habe, dürfte sogar
schon deutlich detaillierter sein von dabei annunzieren, alles klar, ob das jetzt wirklich,
ob das jetzt wirklich absichtlich gehyjacked war oder nicht, ist glaube ich bis heute
nicht raus, aber trotzdem interessant, wie easy das gehen kann, wie easy man das Internet
kaputt machen kann, ja und das habe ich mitbekommen, Hetzner Cloud, Moment mal, ne, Hetzner Cloud
wird nicht teurer, ich glaube, die Cloud-Kisten, die haben nach wie vor die gleiche, da ist
glaube ich kein Unterschied, die IPv4-Adressen kosten jetzt was, wenn man diese feste IPv4-Adressen
einrichten lassen will, das ist jetzt glaube ich neu, ach die Cloud ist auch teurer, ja
dann, wenn die Cloud teurer wird, dann sollte ich auch mehr Provision für die Werbung verlangen,
wir sollten das abhängig machen von den Cloud-Preisen, ne, also das hier habe ich gelesen,
zum Beispiel, dass man jetzt, wenn man den Dedicated Server hatten sich IPs anlegen lassen
will, dass man 22€ Setup bezahlen muss und sowas, ab August oder so, gell, was und Cloud
wird teurer, wo steht denn das, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, OKS, was war denn das?
Die kleine Cloud-Kiste auf, wer sagt das, wo habt ihr das gesehen?
Ja, das mit IPv6, das ist ja eine coole Geschichte, es funktioniert ja auch, ich hätte gar keine
Probleme mit alles nur per IPv6 anzubieten, wenn du aber öffentliche Services anbietest,
dann kommst du aktuell nicht umher, dass zumindest noch jetzt mal wahrscheinlich ein paar Jahre
zusätzlich, du kannst ja über IPv6 anbieten, da würde ich auch jeden dazu ermutigen, ja,
wenn er das machen kann, biete es per IPv6 an, aber du brauchst auf jeden Fall, so wie
übrigens der Preis-Champ auch per IPv6 erreichbar ist, oh, warum ist das kaputt, ist das wirklich
kaputt, RIP, warum ist der Preis-Champ broken, sag bloß die Festplatte ist voll, OK, da muss
ich nachher gucken, was mit dem Preis-Champ los ist, weiß nicht, was da ist, ist gerade
irgendwie was im Arsch hier oder so, Gatschi-Buzz, what the fuck, geht auch Google nicht auf,
was ist hier los, der der, der, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den, den,